hocus à présent sur les écoles de
tourlaville en compte 58 dont 11
nécessite de gros travaux de rénovation
la municipalité vient de 6 10 ans de
s'engager à y consacrer 73 millions
d'euros
exemple du côté de l'école maternelle
jean-de-la-fontaine à tours-nord un
bâtiment construit en 1968 et qui va
finalement être détruit aurélie renault
fin des années 60 l'école jean de la
fontaine accueille ses premiers élèves
aujourd'hui elle compte quatre classes
dont une hébergés à côté à l'école
élémentaire faute de place en 2022 les
bâtiments seront démolis et voilà à quoi
ressemblera la nouvelle école livré en
un bâtiment en matériaux biosourcés du
bois de l'isolant paille et une
ventilation naturelle la reconstruction
comprend également un nouveau restaurant
scolaire une garderie et un city stade
heureusement les 58 écoles de la ville
ne sont pas des passoires thermiques
mais il y en a moins au global 20 à 25
sur lesquels il va falloir travailler
sur l'aspect énergétique vous souvenez
quand en 2016 il ya des écoles qui
étaient inutilisables c'est à dire qu'on
a demandé aux enfants de rester chez eux
tellement les conditions de confort ils
n'étaient pas adaptés en période de
canicule donc on pouvait on peut pas
continuer comme ça c'était une priorité
annoncée est encore une fois après un
mandat où on aura eu juste la
construction d'une nouvelle école nous
on annonce des travaux sur onze écoles
le maire de tours a fait ses comptes son
plan école coûtent 73 millions d'euros
avec les aides européennes et régionales
la ville devrait absorber un peu moins
de la moitié du budget six écoles seront
démolie et reconstruite pour les cinq
autres on annonce une rénovation
énergétique serait de l'isolément par
l'extérieur reprise des menuiseries
et souvent mise en place d'une
ventilation pour pouvoir a erré en
soirée la nuit quand il fait plus frais
les bâtiments là c'est vraiment pour la
partie confort d'été fini les cours
d'école sans ombre c'est ce qu'annonce
la ville de tours elle compte troqué le
bitume contre des copeaux de bois comme
ici dans la future école jean de la
fontaine le mot d'ordre du maire comme
un peu partout dans la ville
c'est la végétalisation